[Musique]
merci samsung merci samsung le 13 avril
dernier vous sortez une vidéo pour vous
présenter le samsung galaxy à 52 5 g le
smartphone qui avait le potentiel de se
vendre le mieux sur l'année pour samsung
oui parce que forcément les smartphones
qui se vendent le mieux ce ne sont pas
les smartphones qui vont coûter 1500
euros ce ne sont pas les smartphones qui
vont coûter 1000 ronnie 900 euros ce
sont les smartphones dans le milieu de
gamme c'est là où on fait du volume et
ce sont les smartphones qui se vend le
plus non pas en valeur mais en volume on
avait déjà fait les années précédentes
le à 51 le a50 est tous les ans ses
smartphones s'enchaînent est arrivé les
à 50,2 kita très bon smartphone et
j'étais frustré sur un point
alors là où je vais trouver un petit peu
moins bon et un peu moins performant par
rapport aux autres modèles c'est sûr
justement la performance ici vous avez
un qualcomm snapdragon
750 g sur le modèle 5 g soit le modèle
4g vous êtes sur un 720 j'ai mon arme
évitez de passer un peu le ces chiffres
un peu marre là je les trouve très bien
franchement une marche bien faire
tourner beaucoup de jeu du plein store
pour venir vous amuser à tout ce que
vous voulez mais vous voyez dans ce
segment de prix à 440 euros je
m'attendrais à voir ce qui se fait de
mieux vous retrouvez la concurrence
destin dragon 7 165 g qui seront plus
performants que le snapdragon 750 g
alors ça se joue à pas grand-chose mais
malgré tout vous avez une différence et
quand je suis consommateur est bien
cette différence allait important pons
et du coup est arrivé quand un tintin
tintin le à 52 s 5 g qui vient corriger
ce problème de performances on passe du
sun ray gun 750 g au snapdragon
778 j'ai alors sous ces chiffres un peu
barbare on a 40 % de performances en
plus on a une optimisation aussi au
niveau graphique ça va aller plus loin
le fait d'avoir plus de performance vous
permettre à quoi d'avoir un meilleur
traitement meilleur calcul d'emmener
aussi une meilleure autonomie et
d'améliorer aussi les parties photo
alors on va pas changer les capteurs on
n'a pas raconter notre histoire raconte
exactement la même histoire non
l'améliorent c'est quand même vachement
bien personnellement j'aime beaucoup et
je trouve que là dessus ils ont vraiment
eu la très bonne idée de faire ça comme
ça parce que ça permet d'emmener
l'expérience
beaucoup plus loin et c'est un truc qui
manquait vraiment à celui qu'on avait il
ya pas longtemps sinon smartphone c'est
exactement le même n'y a pas de
changement ce jour 189 g on a toujours
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
permet de déverrouiller extrêmement
rapidement on a toujours cet écran oled
de 5 pouces full hd + un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz toujours
le vingt neuvième toujours le crâne
gorilla glass 5 toujours des haut
parleurs stéréo toujours une batterie de
4500 millions terreur avec un bloc de
charge de 15 mois incluent même si on
est compatible charge 25 points toujours
avec manuel qui est une super expérience
samsung donc si vous voulez quelque
chose qui marche très très bien en terme
d'expérience logiciels ont eu là et
c'est vraiment génial on a exactement la
même chose au niveau des capteurs alors
à la différence cette fois-ci j'ai pu
faire des photos alors qu'il fait
beaucoup plus beau donc vous allez
parents conditions de très bonne
luminosité ce que ça raconte regardez là
j'ai fait des photos à contre-jour et
bien malgré tout il arrive quand même à
venir repérer et bien le fond la porte
en tout cas ça c'est vraiment vraiment
sympa sur l'ultra grand temps que c'est
pareil ça marche bien mais une très très
bonne gestion des lumières ici c'est
vraiment très très bien on peut se
rapprocher un petit peu voyez bon
toujours un peu la même sauce à quand on
se met trop c'est pas terrible là c'est
toute la gestion des lumières lorsqu'il
fait beau et bien ça marche vraiment
bien et c'est pour ça que ce smartphone
est un excellent photophone dans le
milieu de gamme regardez là vous avez ce
tollé qui vient éclairer cette façade ça
marche vraiment bien alors je vous ai
fait l' ultra grand-angle juin ou même
un petit peu c'est un très très grand
classique la caméra de celle fille à
contre-jour elle est un peu en dessous
si vous la prenez avec le soleil en face
de vous et bien ça ira tout de suite
beaucoup mieux bon là j'ai une tête un
peu du mec qui transpirait cachot mais
sinon ça va pas mal donc regarder quand
même franchement il ya très très beau
boulot qui fait ici le soleil et de
l'autre côté là c'est plus dans l'ombre
une fois de plus ça marche vachement
bien c'est un petit peu cramé ici au
niveau des cheminées les bons voilà on
peut pas non plus demander la lune mais
une fois de plus le rendu est là pareil
je suis dans l'ombre on a le soleil en
face et bien c'est vraiment bien très
très bonne plage dynamique que ce soit
sur l' ultra grand-angle sur le grand
temps que l'on peut venir jouer un petit
peu enfin bref ça va vraiment bien là
c'est pareil regardez là on l'est sous
une arche on est dans l'ombre complète
on arrive quand même avoir un bout de
ciel bleu c'est pas mal on a bien la
façade on a les voitures et sur l'ultra
grand temps que c'est exactement la même
chose donc c'est vraiment un très très
beau boulot que vous a fait samsung ici
on peut venir regarder plein de photos
c'est vraiment un excellent photophone
dans le milieu de gamme grand angle
ultra grand temps quand il fait très
beau lorsqu'il fait un peu moins beau le
grand temps ne travaille en tant que ça
un peu moins terrible mais fera le
boulot la macro en oublie j'aime pas la
caméra de celle fille elle ira le mode
portrait c'est aussi un peu en dessous
on peut filmer en 4k 30 images par
secondes ça c'est le maximum voyez comme
ça on some petit tour du studio il peut
faire chaud il peut faire beau il ya des
scooters du bruit quels changements
lumière ça c'est pas mal dont les donc
là tout de suite on eût hd 4k usd à 30
images par seconde
alors là il ya un mot qui est super
stabilisé qui n'existait pas le cas là
je suis hors 1080p à 60 images par
seconde et si je veux le mode super
stabiliser et à chanter sont toujours en
1080p à 30 images par seconde est donc
là ça vient petit peu kron payant
l'image j'espère que ça ira je me rends
pas du tout content placer la caméra de
celle fille en 60 images par seconde et
là je suis en 30 images par seconde
regardez les galères pour rouler en vélo
à paris les mecs ils se garent n'importe
où ils bloquent les voies pour les vélos
ça me semblait pas être important de
vous parler de la partie vidéo sur des
smartphones de milieu de gamme mais en
fait comme aujourd'hui beaucoup de
personnes font de la vidéo sociaux tik
tok hun ce tarif ses compagnes et même
temps les smartphones qui coûte par huit
cent mille euros eh bien on utilise
quand même pas mal la fonction vidéo
donc ça me paraît normal de venir en
parler on s'en va de plus en plus comme
ça
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
on a toujours une certification ip67
doubla nothin on you see plus carte
microsd jusqu'à un terrain toujours de
neuf c'est toujours difficile et un
smartphone qui coûte 459 euros y'a pas
un grand changement entre la 52e à 52 s
5 g lors il existe une version 4g mais
la version 4g pour le coup on va
vraiment l'oublier parce que le
processeur ne sera pas assez performant
et vu ce qu'on a ici avec un regain de
performance pour venir jouer à des jeux
c'est vachement bien si vous avez besoin
d'un complément d'information vous
invite à venir voir ma vidéo sur le à 52
5 g le lien est quelque part en bas ou
en haut ici je sais pas le lien est
quelque part en tout cas vous le
trouverez ce qui est sûr dans la
description parce que ce smartphone la
c1 à 52 avec le s est peut-être pour au
spi 2 je sais pas avec ce nouveau
processeur et la possibilité d'avoir une
couleur menthe donc je suis très content
que samsung ait entendu cette question
de problèmes de performance je suis pas
sûr que ça me sauve encore aimer écouter
- je suis pas sûr que le commentaire de
monsieur reçoit suffisamment importante
pour que ça tourne d'une bonne qu'un
monsieur nous a raison on va sortir une
version rs mais pour qu'il sorte une
version boostée c'est que j'ai pas été
le seul à le dire donc petit à petit
j'ai mis ma pierre à l'édifice donc là
ça me plaît voilà à vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez ce que vous avez
acheté le a5 andorre si vous l'avez vous
le gardez ne changeait pas ça sert à
rien ce qu'ils ont sur iphone trop
souvent mais si vous ne l'avez pas
acheter et que vous vous posez la
question à 52 s 5g smartphones
performants très bon photos très cool au
niveau de l'autonomie l'expérience
logiciels et hop il est résistant à
l'eau c'est une expérience globale qui
est vraiment bien pour 459 euros et en
plus il a encore des pré commande sur le
site de samsung jusqu'au 15 octobre ils
vous offrent une google nest audio qui
le remplaçant du google chrome et ça
c'est vachement bien bravo et merci
samsung
[Musique]